e eu parto
Oi hoje é o parto depois de me partir em
várias eu parto depois de tantas vezes
voltar dos nossos a Deus eu parto para
longe do que nunca me pertenceu hoje é o
quarto depois de você me partir enquanto
eu só quis partilhar as mais belas
coisas do seu lado meu olho Vitral ver o
cores nas suas falhas flores nas suas
desculpas beleza nas suas migalhas eu
aceitei tudo na espera de um dia ser
parte de um inteiro com você com você
foi feito aberto carta aberta poesia
declarada por bilhete de geladeira para
você talvez lembrar que eu mereço ser
inteiramente amada e que difícil não é
me amar e me enxergar para além das
partículas e particularmente eu achei
que está do seu lado seria o bastante
mas ilusão de ótica foi te ver tirar o
brilho dos meus olhos e procurar por
outros olhos mais brilhantes lembra de
quase morreu afogada nos meus olhos
oceano de todas as vezes que me vi
sozinha nadando em círculos achando que
a culpa era minha lembro
eu tive medo de falar de fazer de errar
de saber da insuficiência que consumiu o
meu ser de todas as vezes que o seu ego
custou Minha Paz lembra de dizer não
aguento mais então você voltou dizendo
tava mudado para esquecer do passado
Depois de tanto também partido Mas você
voltou para ficar no talvez você voltou
para mim partir mais uma vez eu vi a
história se repetindo então eu parto eo
parto por escrito para não ser
interrompida eu parto já bem longe é que
eu odeio despedida eu parto sem aviso e
partes em Sorriso meu parto sabendo
sobre tudo que não querem nem preciso
hoje é o quarto por todas as vezes que
fui monumento e você me tratou como
miniatura meu parto sabendo que Nem tudo
são flores e que você nunca me deu
flores porque nem fez semeadura e depois
de ver no meu peito uma cicatriz enorme
com a sua assinatura
o meu parto eu parto Porque meu corpo é
só o sagrado eu parto porque não se rega
flores mortas muito menos artificiais eu
sou eu quero eu posso eu mereço muito
mais esse ontem fui desespero e tristeza
hoje levanto com mais certeza de que
nada de estranho uma mulher Fortaleza
minhas marcas me lembram que eu não saí
leis aí que a cura não via de nada além
de mim mesma então eu comigo me levanto
o vento seca meu pranto e o Renato da
Chamas queimaram minha própria pele eu
comigo me refaço e das partes que você
me partiu eu uma uma faça um mosaico dia
após dia recolhi os cacos me faça o
coragem refaça o meu peito em colagem
observa o meu corpo paisagem e leva o
meu eu mais verdadeiro para me lembrar
que eu só parte
e por amar alguém que nunca meu amor por
inteiro
é muito obrigada